what was your first like red pill moment
um I'm gonna say it probably started
with a divorce when you know you're you
married the wrong person okay this isn't
gonna work out I don't want to spend the
rest of my life trying to fix something
that's not fixable let's just untie this
knot and call it a day
um it's not as easy as that and I think
the first red pilling moment was when I
got on the phone with my family lawyer
and he did the prenup for me too and I
got on the phone with him you know a few
years later and I said look you know I
think this isn't going to work out we
need to get out of this uh you know how
do we get the ball rolling sort of thing
and he it was a half an hour
conversation I'm driving my car and I
was in a position where I was just like
are you serious like this this is how
things go in family law I thought you
just got divorced I didn't realize that
you've got issues to deal with like
false domestic violence charges you're
probably not going to see your kid if
you're a father you don't want to go to
court you're going to lose you know all
of these things that sort of popped up
in the conversation I'm like well hold
on a second I thought men and women were
equal like didn't feminism level the
playing field for everybody and we can
just part ways but no it's not that
simple so that was probably the first
red pilling moment I think it's also one
of the first red pilling moments for a
lot of guys too is when they start going
through the divorce machine as well
there's definitely a lot of sticky areas
in there and whether if kids are
involved or in sort of like the the
direction that that usually goes with
custody or I don't know I I have been
divorced but I don't have kids
um but also just you know even talking
about like allegations like women do get
away with a lot I really think there's a
lot on both sides like there's a lot
that men get away with there's a lot
that women get away with and it's a
matter of just stopping the [__] of
getting away with some something and
just be have integrity and have honor
and do the right thing that's what you'd
hope for but the reality isn't that from
the perspective of the usually the leave
or because there's a levy and a leave
ore yeah and and the person leaving the
other that wants to stay in the
relationship doesn't want it to end so
you're in a bad bargaining position if
you're a dude leaving a woman and she
wants you to stay and family law is
almost completely on her side well to be
honest family law is mostly completely
on the side of the person that makes
more money that brought more to the
table if you have kids it's also on the
side of the person that gave birth to
the kid in most instances because women
are a hypergamous by Nature they tend to
marry a cross and up on the social
economic scale so they tend to marry up
to guys for the most part not all women
do
um so guys are in a position where they
have to deal with that whole okay well
what do I deal with you know like how do
I deal with everything I brought to the
table how do I deal with my future
income you know the notion that someone
that you married for a few years has
rights to a decade or decades or even a
lifetime of your future income is
absolutely absurd to me given that men
and women are equal under the you know
the guys of you know feminism today
let's talk about that hypergamy I
basically sit here in my life and go
[__] like what do I do right I If a
woman dates lateral and up and a
mandates or sorry a woman dates lateral
and up in a mandate sort of lateral and
down when it comes to success and
finances status and a woman is
intelligent that hurts her earning
intelligence whatever like what the f
what do I do I'll tell guys in honesty
that you're in a better position to
marry a woman that's on the same part as
you if not higher right because that
almost removes most of the risk of
losing your nest egg in any future
income
um my ex-wife's a lawyer you know she's
very successful
um so that really wasn't a huge issue as
far as you know nest egg and a division
of assets it was more dealing with you
know the child custody issues with that
daughter
um but for women that you know like you
like I assume that you've done well in
life you know you've race cars
um I don't know you know what the total
record is although I am a huge card
Enthusiast but I don't watch racing I
don't it's weird because I love driving
supercars but I don't like watching
other people drive super cars I don't
find it as interesting to drive them
myself yeah all right not gonna lie I
don't watch that much racing but now
that I do more commentating and I'm a
host for I do a little bit for F1 NASCAR
and IndyCar I obviously keep up with
everything but yeah yeah I really find
the job they did on the Netflix series
um drive to survive really good on the
formula one thing but it's it's it's got
to be difficult for you if you're a
successful woman to find a guy and get
into a long-term relationship because
the thing with successful older guys is
like Med Peak a little bit later on in
life than women do right like men reach
their sexual Market peak in their late
30s and the thing that women don't like
is they peak in their early 20s and
that's just an unfortunate reality of
this Sexes and it's always been that way
men have always been success objects to
women and women have always been Beauty
objects to men so men tend to date
younger women go into Peak though what
does peak mean well
um men are valued based on on their
competency skills what they can do
um you know that like that little Dent
that they can put in the universe sort
of thing whereas men don't usually care
about women's degrees they don't usually
show a lot of interest in their degrees
on the wall framed in Mahogany with
little letters after the name sort of
thing it's Grand and it's Noble and all
that sort of stuff but there's no guy
that ever said oh yeah look at the
degree on her right guys will look at a
woman and say look at whatever on her
she's walking away sort of thing that's
how men operate you know they're they're
visual in the sense that they see women
as Beauty objects and they've always
been treated as Beauty objects even
though Society tries to change that
today so Peak then for women's
appearance is earlier value actually
um yeah it's actually based on a lot I
understand what the peak is and if Peak
is uh fertility is Peaks money is Peak
beauty is what's what's the peak well
that's that's the definition that
they're trying to change today right
because we women have valued men based
on what they can bring to the table
right like what resources they have
available to them to provide and preside
over the family and the children and
protect and all that sort of stuff uh
women's value has historically always
been around their beauty and their
fertility
um you know when they survey
cross-culturally across all continents
all religions and they show a lineup of
every man from 18 to like 75 I think the
survey was done under uh you know lineup
of women from all ages all the way up to
75 from 20. the universally almost all
pick about 22 23 year old women you know
as far as like beauty standards so
that's just the way that societies
always operated so as a beautiful
attractive woman maybe you know such as
yourself that's also had a successful
career that's competent influential on
social media uh does commentating you
know let's say on racing events and
stuff like that but
um there's not a lot of guys that are
like oh my God she's
um you know her voice or or her
commentary on that program is so
valuable to me what guys look at is the
beauty aspect of a woman right like
that's that's why women wear makeup dye
their hair you know wear push-up bras
and accentuate you know their body
curves and their lines with things like
heels and stuff like that
um as much as Society wants to change
that today and say things like You're
Beautiful at any weight like that's one
of the big lies that I think that
feminism tells women is you're beautiful
at any size it's just not true right
there are standards that men are drawn
to when it comes to beauty and obesity
is not one of them not healthy either
like it's not healthy like I wouldn't
want to invite a woman that's obese and
diabetic into my life I don't want to
deal with that there's a evil
psychologist his name's Dr Ware Dr
Warren Farrell uh he's written several
books I think one one of the ones that
stood out was uh the myth of male power
and he's done a few others like the boy
crisis and things like that one of the
observations that he made over his
career like you know Decades of of
studying all this material is basically
that you can distill it down to that men
are success objects and women are Beauty
objects and that's how the Sexes view
each other do you think that's right it
doesn't matter if it's right or wrong
it's just how we've always viewed each
other throughout history I don't know I
mean
I think we we don't grow and evolve
without a discussion without changes
so it would imply that there's nothing
wrong with anything and that there's no
need to grow and evolve and
you know I think that I don't know I
think that there's still a discussion
around that is that the right thing is
that is that right because they think
that you know when we expand on that and
we go into like value I think I saw
something that you had written that said
like if you took sex out of the uh
relationship 90 of women would have
nothing to offer yeah and if you took
money out of the relationship the 90 of
men would have nothing to offer women
explain that that's actually something
that I came across in comedy believe it
or not I get a lot of my material from
Comedy that I you know summarize in my
videos in my social media so if men lost
their their status their success the
wealth or influence their competency uh
in society then 90 of women probably
wouldn't stay with those guys like the
reason why women generally leave
relationships and marriages and women
leave marriages 80 of the time it's not
generally men that leave marriages it's
generally women that leave and when
women leave it's because they feel like
they can do better with another guy
right um this guy that I'm married to
that I've had my 2.1 kids in the white
picket fence in the station wagon he
just sits around and watches Sports all
day he's put on 150 pounds he can't keep
a job down he doesn't even know how to
change the light bulb I have to call my
dad to come over and take care of stuff
like that these are the sorts of things
that women don't want to deal with right
so when I speak to Men I'm constantly
telling them chase Excellence right like
you can't let your guard down you can't
retire you cannot stop you know pursuing
passion you cannot stop putting a dent
in Universe because if your wife your
woman your girlfriend wakes up in the
morning and she looks at you and thinks
to herself I'm stuck with a loser
there's a good chance she's probably
going to leave because marriage isn't
forever anymore you know the nod is
untied all the time
um we're not particularly good as a
species at monogamy so that's where that
notion comes from and on the flip side
of the coin I mean if a woman is like 90
of guys would leave relationships if sex
was removed from the equation if his
wife or his girlfriend all of a sudden
announced and said look I'm just going
to become celibate I've gotten right
with God I don't want to have sex
anymore I'm going to become you know the
Virgin Mary whatever he's going to be
like huh that's interesting because the
reason why I'm here is for access to
easy frequent and you know amazing sex
that's why you guys get married that's
it that's the main reason why guys are
getting married believe it or not they
think that when they get see the biggest
complaint that guys have when they get
married if you take a look at their
Google search history as they start
looking up words like why doesn't my
wife want to bang me why doesn't my wife
want to have sex with me how do I get my
wife to have sex with me could you
imagine being married as a man and
you're Google searching how do I get my
wife to have sex with me there's a lot
of marriages out there that are
completely sexless right so when you
remove sex from the equation and the sad
part of it is a lot of guys they won't
change that they'll just resort to
something like pornography so they won't
leave the relationship they won't end
their marriage it's generally not to
their advantage to do that because
they'll lose so much so they'll just
stay
lose what
could be wealth could be future wealth
could be access to their kids it depends
it could be all those things so you're
saying there's nothing else that a woman
offers if it isn't sex they don't offer
Comfort they don't offer safety they
don't offer a companionship they don't
offer taking care of things they don't
offer planning nice things for someone
they don't offer cooking or cleaning or
I didn't say that like anything like
that no I didn't say that but women
don't offer safety to me I offer safety
to women yeah but all the other stuff
you're talking about Comfort
companionship love all that sort of
stuff of course but the main reason why
men get into relationships with women is
for sex what areas of value is it that
you believe a woman has Beyond has to be
more than sex well I I have greater
standards it just sex right like I have
girlfriends exactly you know she's got
great culinary skills she's fun to be
around we laugh we joke we have similar
interests like I like cycling so we go
for bike rides a lot in the summertime
so it's it's beyond just sex but the
main reason why men mate select a woman
is because of sexual intimacy that's
just the way like that's why we're here
on the earth to scatter seed right we're
not here to build skyscrapers and Roads
and drive electric cars we're here to
scatter seeds like that's our buy that's
our biological imperative I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out